hi YouTube um so I don't really have a
genius idea but I think I have two
suggestions that of what we need in this
world one is a new humanistic vision
that is not built around a nationality
and ethnicity or rather around humanity
something that doesn't exclude anyone or
any group but really is built around our
universal characteristics that sure that
we should hold in common the second is
and I think we need to change your view
that we are really have to think about
how we build a better world for the next
generation one that's better than the
one that was given to us and it seems
that in the short one world we often
think what we can get out of this world
rather than making sure that we are
passing on something better than what we
inherited that's it